nothing absolutely nothing would be as
devastating as the Direct Hit of a
gamma-ray burst from within our galaxy
The Milky Way as the burst was
approaching the planet photons would be
pulling the ozone layer away and causing
chemical reactions on Earth
you'd see a cloud of photochemical smog
covering the planet
we'd be blasted with all sorts of cosmic
rays they would damage our electronics
and bring us lethal doses of radiation
you'd witness another wave of mass
extinction on Earth
the good thing is that it doesn't look
like an event like this is likely to
happen for another billion years
by that time we might have figured out
how to move the Earth out of the danger
zone